quería hablar un poquito más en detalle
sobre esto un informe de teja de
derechos y Justicia global emirando los
últimos cuatro años de interinos de
datos de asesinatos y atentados contra
contra precandidatos de candidatos en
Brasil muestra que hay 327 casos de
letales o sea de asesinatos y atentados
contra precandidatos y candidatos y solo
este año de de enero
a septiembre tenemos 27 casos de
asesinatos y atentados y en unos casos
emblemáticos que creo que muestra un
poco ese cambio de Panorama en términos
de como esa polarización está pasando a
hacer más violenta Más allá del debate
en sí mismo es por ejemplo la muerte de
la concejal de pozol que es un partido
de izquierda en Río de Janeiro en 2018
María elefante que fue que tomó
proporciones bastante incluso
internacionales hasta ahora no han
encontrado los Auto materiales de no han
podido esos autores materiales de la
sociedad María Eli Franco tenemos el
atentado el asesinato de un partido del
partido de trabajadores en julio de este
año por parte de un policial también
partidas vosonario son ejemplo ejemplos
como también del otro lado creo que hay
de los dos lados no hay ese ejemplos
congelación a partidos partidarios
candidatos de izquierda pero también hay
también por ejemplo la familia de
posicionaron su su sentimiento y su
carro todo lo la habían acabado con
carros de la esposa de emocional
entonces muestra que están por las vías
de hecho y eso pues pierde la democracia
de Brasil en la medida que esa
polinización pues va los días de hecho
por la forma de violenta pues no
logramos hacer debates sobre programas
sobre políticas y
y las figuras los programas de los
partidos
dejan de tener sentido y lo que que
aparece en la en la disputa son los
contrincantes no son sonaron la figura
busonaro Y vos sonar y y Lula Y creo que
eso Brasil pierde con con esos datos
creo que es un escenario bastante triste
y que ha aumentado y la sociedad pierde
su impulso para reclamar alzar su voz
exigir eso se va reflejado en una
encuesta que tengo acá el dato que tres
de cada cuatro votantes en Brasil es
decir el 67,5%
teme sufrir agresiones por motivos
políticos en este país suramericano es
una encuesta que hizo la firma datafolia
y pues que muestra un poco el panorama
claro del tema de la de la violencia
política que no es nuevo no es
particular de esta elección sino que ya
viene de años atrás pero que pues de
Cara a estas elecciones presidenciales y
hasta polarización pues se va a re
también importante hablar de el tema de
las mujeres simones Lo ponía sobre la
mesa
solamente vemos destacada una candidata
que llega a la tercera posición de la
votación
y sigue siendo una deuda pendiente las
mujeres bien destacadas en la escena
política brasileña las hay Pero sigue
faltando sigue faltando porque las
mujeres en Brasil son más de 50% Somos
52%
Del electoral en Brasil y pues somos la
deberíamos debería haber además pues
representaciones O sea que ellos debería
reflejar más en términos de la
composición del Congreso o un mismo
menos violencia contra las mujeres en la
política creo que el fenómeno es la
violencia parcial de género en la
política
muchas diputadas federales y senadoras
también ha demostrado que la política
continúa haciendo un lugar hostil para
las mujeres
y creo Pues a mí me alegra mucho que han
tenido en esas elecciones presidenciales
que hemos tenido como cuatro candidatos
mujeres y creo que eso es un y como
presidente sino como físico presidentes
no candidatos presidenciales y y y y
cómo van a Teresa comentó creo que los
analistas cuando miraron la la
participación de Simón tvt en los debate
realmente ese día una persona preocupada
en hablar del país entonces creo que eso
muestra que hay fuerza y y por ejemplo
entre los electores de lulas 50% de las
mujeres son a favor de Lula creo que ahí
muestra unas tendencias y unos patrones
muy importantes de tener en cuenta para
el segundo turno